You’ve probably heard this song
sampled in hundreds of Hip Hop tracks.
But did you know that Bam Bam by
Sister Nancy is a sample itself?
Jamaican dancehall is a genre
that originated during the 1970s
and is rooted in the art of sampling.
So when Sister Nancy was in the studio in 1982,
she was inspired by Yellowman who had
created a Bam Bam song around the same time.
But Yellowman’s chorus actually originates
in the 1966 song Bam Bam by The Maytals.
Sister Nancy then completely freestyled new lyrics
on top of a different beat pulled
from Stalag 17 by Ansel Collins.
So now when you hear a rap
song sample Bam Bam today,
you’ll know that song is a
sample of a sample of a sample.